Snooki told us for her and Jionni
divorce is not an option do you feel
like you and Roger live by that same
mentality no no cuz their third
deal-breakers in our relationship
Jenni Farley aka JWoww has a pretty
serious message for estranged husband
Roger Matthews the Jersey Shore star
shared a very heated open letter on her
website Wednesday addressed to Roger
who's been publicly feuding with her
since she filed for divorce in September
my ex cannot control her emotions in
front of our children and and literally
turns my child against me JWoww also
posted a handful of disturbing videos
which appear to show the pair fighting
and things get physical
et reached out to a rep for Roger who
told us quote at this time we will not
be giving a comment on this matter
JWoww's letter starts by saying she
tried to resolve their issues out of the
spotlight for the sake of their children
but now she says quote I can no longer
sit idly by while you mistreat and
malign me JWoww claims Roger has been
doing a number of harmful things
including sharing false statements and
endangering their children quote you are
an abuser to the core Roger Mathews if
this was not enough you have spit at me
you have pushed me you have shoved me
you have aggressively thrown me to the
ground you have belittled and disparaged
me JWoww ended her post by sharing
several court documents alleged text
messages and videos supporting her
claims et sat down with a reality star
in September 2016 when she candidly
addressed the ups and downs in her then
marriage to Roger third deal-breakers in
our relationship that we would separate
over I think yeah I like the cheating or
you know Affairs things like that things
that you can't go back like you can't go
back in time and fix coz like what I
always say like when the damage is done
it's done but yeah I would never say
it's not an option because if you're
truly unhappy you shouldn't stay in a
relationship